okay what's up robcor
what's up robcort robco we gotta watch
yes yes
we have a watch it is a very cool one so
damier swiss sent me
a watch it's a justice league watch and
the idea was to unbox it review it
and let you guys know what i think about
it uh i'm excited about this
i'm very very excited about this this
whole watch that we got is actually
designed to build off of the
justice league film the snyder cut of
the justice league that's coming up
so they're all themed watches the
package is a little rough this is not
dummier swiss that did this it's dhl
you want to specify that who cares about
that box wow that's a
big box yes it is for a watch yes it is
this is really cool
[Music]
okay let us hit the
thing all the time oh it does yeah
come here i think that's how you
pronounce it dummy or swiss oh hopefully
yeah i mean that's really dumb yeah i'm
pronouncing it incredibly wrong
don't worry guys by the way i'll give
you guys an up-close look at the whole
unboxing process after myself and mariah
opened it up so you guys can see what it
looks like because you know you have to
do like
the official like b-roll buttery smooth
like
the watch is crafted in this material
what's the way that i don't
[Music]
wow wow
don't worry you guys will see it no
you're super up close don't worry
i'm not going to leave you guys hanging
really really fancy
it does look really fancy yeah it comes
with a solid card look at that i thought
it was a credit card
i was like the back credit card that is
nice
oh man yes guys yeah
i don't know if you guys can see it wow
this thing has some weight to it
this thing has some weight to it i love
the weight of this thing
this card is guaranteed that the watch
is worldwide limited edition
yes damn
that's how you know it's legit yeah this
is awesome here
feel that watch it's got weight to it
you can mess somebody up with that watch
man
this is a batman watch i was hoping it
had other gadgets inside like little
mini baby banging ring
bang rings batarangs
but no this is really nice yeah you can
mess somebody up man you go rolling on
somebody with this watch they're gonna
be like
what right yeah no it has
a little bat insignia in the middle yeah
and it's it's kind of odd in the way it
tells time because
the so there's like a thing for i think
the
seconds the minutes and the hours yes
and i think the thing like stays a
little
try like panel thing
stays put but like the things move to
show what time it is but yeah no it
looks really good
yes it does it's moving already yeah i
didn't mean to turn it on was it all the
whole line
it's a swiss watch sweetheart these
things are not designed to mess up
oh regardless it is a gorgeous watch it
really really is
this thing is beautiful it's got a
plastic cover on the front
okay so now that we've unboxed this
let's do the buttery
smooth b-roll unboxing process as is par
for the course
on the youtubes you have to do it like
they do on the prices right
you have to you know
you know oh man okay we're gonna cut to
the b-roll
so along with this limited edition
batman watch damier swiss
sent me an affiliate link which you can
find in the description
which will get you an additional
one-year warranty
now the watch itself is superb it has a
nice weight to it
along with a sleek and stylish design
that complements my preference for
comic themed apparel
so if you're looking for official dc
comics themed watches to complement your
sense of style
check out the link down in the
description and use my affiliate code
to claim your limited edition justice
league watch
[Applause]
[Music]
you